let's say that we have some particle
that's moving along the number line so
let me draw a number line right over
here so that's our number line right
over there now let's say it starts right
over here at zero and then as time
passes this little point is going to
move around maybe it moves to the right
slows down speeds up maybe moves to the
left slows down speeds up it might do
all sorts of things and to describe this
motion its position as a function of
time we have a function s of T this
particles position as a function of time
we're given is T to the third power
minus six T squared plus nine T and
we're going to restrict the domain to
positive time so we're going to assume
the time is greater than or equal to
zero now the question that we want to
answer in this video is when is this
particle speeding up so when are we
speeding up speeding speeding up and I
think that bears a little clarification
what does it mean to speed up well
there's two scenarios if the particle is
already moving in the rightward
direction so if it's already moving in
the right or directions and the way that
we would know it's moving in the
rightward direction is if its velocity
is greater than zero if it's moving in
the rightward direction and it's also
accelerating in the rightward direction
so if its acceleration is also greater
than zero then this is a situation where
we are speeding up now another scenario
where we would be speeding up is if
we're moving in the leftward direction
in that case our velocity is going to be
negative so if our velocity is negative
and we want to go faster in the negative
direction then our acceleration should
also be negative we're going to that
would make our velocity getting more and
more and more negative with time so then
our acceleration needs to also be
negative if we still if we still want to
be speeding up if you have any other
combination here if your velocity is
negative but your acceleration is
positive that means that you're becoming
less your velocity is becoming less
negative or you'd be slowing down in the
left
direction and vice-versa so if your
velocity is positive in your
acceleration is negative that means you
are going to the right but you are
slowing down in the right or directions
so let's think about these two scenarios
and since velocity matters here so much
we just have to remind ourselves that
the velocity the velocity remember a
derivative is just the rate of change
rate of change with respect to a
variable so if you have your position
function the derivative of position with
respect to time this is really just how
what is the instantaneous rate of change
of position with respect to time well
what is change of position with respect
to time well that is just going to be
that's going to be equal to our velocity
function that's going to be equal to our
velocity function V of T or we could
write that s prime of T s prime of T
which could be also written this way as
DS DT is equal to our velocity as a
function of time so let's take the
derivative of this our velocity as a
function of time is going to be equal to
C 3 T squared 3 T squared minus 12t
minus 12t plus 9 plus 9 so let's see if
we can if we can graph this velocity
function to start making sense of it
whether when is the velocity positive
when is it negative and what's the
acceleration doing in those intervals
and so to help me graph it we already we
can find that that we could say the the
the V intercept or the vertical
intercept when V of 0 is going to be
equal to 9 so that'll help us graph it
that's where we intersect the vertical
axis but also let's plot let's plot
let's figure out where it intersects the
where it intersects the T axis so let's
set this equal to 0 so 3t squared minus
12t plus 9 is equal to 0 see to simplify
this I can divide both sides by 3 and I
get T squared minus 4t plus 3 is equal
to 0 now this is very factorable this is
T let's see what what two numbers when
you take a product get 3 and when you
add them you get negative 4 well it's
going to be t minus 3 times t minus 1 is
equal to 0 how can this expression be
equal to 0 well if either of these are
equal to 0 if either t minus 3 0 or t
minus 1 is 0
- equal to zero so T could be equal to
three or T could be equal to one if T is
three or T is one either of these are
equal to zero and or this entire
expression up here is going to be equal
to zero and since our coefficient on the
T squared term is positive we know this
is going to be an upward-opening
parabola so let's see if we can plot if
we can plot velocity as a function of
time so that is my velocity axis this
right over here is my time axis time
axis and let's say this is one time is 1
second or I'm assuming this is in
seconds 2 3 4 actually let me spread
them apart a little bit more just
because 1 & 3 are significant 1 2 & 3 &
is they're not going to be I'm going to
squash the vertical scale a little bit
but this right over here let's say that
is 9 a velocity of 9 and so when T
equals zero our velocity is 9 when T
equals 1 then this that our velocity is
going to be zero this is we get that
right over here 3 minus 12 plus 9 that's
zero and when T is equal to 3 our
velocity is zero again our vertex is
going to be right in between those when
T is equal to two right in between these
two zeros and we could figure out what
that what that velocity is if we like 3
it's going to be 3 times 4 minus 12
times 2 plus 9 so what is that that's 12
minus 24 plus 9 so that is negative 12
plus 9 so that's going to be equal to
negative 3 did I do that 12 yet negative
3 so you're going to be negative 3 might
be that's 9 so that's positive so it
might be something like this so the
graph of our velocity is a function of
time it's going to look something like
this we only care about positive time
it's going to look something like this
so let's think
remember this is velocity this is our
velocity as
a function of time now let's think about
when is the velocity less than zero and
the acceleration is less than zero so
let's think about this case right over
here
when is this the case both of them are
going to be less than zero
well velocity is less than zero over
this entire interval over this entire
interval this whole entire magenta
interval but the acceleration isn't zero
isn't less than zero that entire time
remember the acceleration is the rate of
change of velocity we can write we can
write here that acceleration as a
function of time this is equal to the
rate of velocity with respect to the
rate which velocity changes with respect
to time or we could write acceleration
is equal to V prime of T which is the
same thing as the second derivative of
position with respect to time and so if
the acceleration you could really think
of the slope of the tangent line of the
velocity function and so over here the
place where this is downward-sloping
where this has a negative slope and the
curve itself is below the T axis that's
only over
that's only over this interval right
over here between between this zero
right over here and and the and the
vertex and we get to this point right
over here and then R then our slope
flattens out so this interval right over
here is T is it's going to be greater
than one and it is going to be less than
two that meets these constraints now
let's think about where our velocity is
greater than zero and our acceleration
is greater than zero well our velocity
is greater than zero over here but
notice our acceleration the slope here
is negative we're downward sloping so
that doesn't apply here our velocity is
greater than zero and our the slope of
the velocity the rate of change of
velocity the acceleration is also
greater than zero so that's this
interval that's this interval right over
here or we're speeding up in the
rightward direction so that interval is
T T is greater than three so when are we
speeding up
we're speeding up between the first and
second seconds and then we're speeding
up after after we're speeding up after
the third second